in this video we're going to talk about
how to flatten your belly in the fastest
time possible and you do see these
videos out there that hey you just need
to drink this one thing or take this one
pill before bed and you will wake up
with a flat stomach well that may only
be true if that belly is really just
coming from bloating and the other very
common question is how many sit-ups do I
have to do how many crunches do I have
to do to achieve a six pack AB first of
all what is your abs well we're talking
about mainly a muscle called the rectus
abdominis and it's not just one muscle
it's a series of little packets of
muscle AKA six pack abs crunches might
make them stronger and a slightly bigger
but that's not the answer for a six-pack
app and when we deal with this rectus
abdominis muscle that muscle is mainly
there to keep the insides your guts from
coming out it's there to stabilize your
torso or your what they called The Core
which is your your entire midsection not
just your front part but your back as
well and so if you're going to do
crunches and you just really focus on
that all the time and you don't at the
same time balance it by working out your
back muscles you are going to develop
either poor posture or back pain so
crunches are good as long as you balance
them out with other types of things but
don't expect to flatten your stomach by
doing crunches that's not the right
thing to do I mean you want to do some
but it's not the thing that's going to
make the big difference and there's two
different types of fat related to your
midsection you have the superficial fat
which is called the subcutaneous it's
right below the skin and then you have
the deeper uh visceral fat that's the
fat around the organs underneath it that
presses it out so right now if you were
just to relax your stomach and if it
extended outward that would be more
visceral fat which is the fat that's
spilling over from the liver Now The
Superficial fat can be best addressed
with diet and a certain type of exercise
which basically is an aerobic or a long
walks or hikes on the same time I also
recommend you do high intensity interval
training because that's going to
stimulate
um certain hormones like growth hormone
and another fat burning hormone called
glucagon and also another fat burning
hormone called testosterone these are
fat burning hormones those are triggered
by intensity of exercise but now the
visceral fat is mainly dealt with
through your diet exercise is important
but diet is way way more important to
get rid of the visceral fat because that
visceral fat is mainly coming from too
much insulin because you're eating too
many carbs you're eating in excess
that's just ending up with extra fat
around the liver and then it spills off
around the abdominal area so just by
going on a low carb diet within two
weeks you literally have the ability to
remove
up to 50 percent of the fat off the
liver okay and then you give it more
time and then you're going to see your
stomach start shrinking more and more
and more all right let's shift gears to
uh fat burning foods okay
now these are foods that stimulate the
fat burning hormones so exercise is one
way to stimulate fat burning hormones
but certain foods can also do it like
protein for example protein can simulate
not just growth hormone and testosterone
but that other hormone called glucagon
as well and so people have these protein
shakes sometimes they do the green
shakes or protein powders combined with
low starch vegetables so really the meat
and vegetables put you in a state of
what's called ketosis where your body is
starting to burn fat so you notice I
didn't say a high fat diet because
that's not necessarily what keto is it's
low carb one big reason I do recommend
adding more fat initially to that diet
is because it makes it easier to fast
for longer periods of time because
you're more satisfied and then when you
start to lose more fat you might want to
cut that back if you're really targeting
the midsection because what we want to
have happen is we want you in a state of
fat burning but but if at the same time
you are eating things that are causing a
fat storage situation or stimulating the
fat making hormone that's called insulin
it's the thing that nullifies all the
good work when you eat carbs I'm talking
about refined carbs like the bread pasta
cereal crackers biscuits fruit sodas all
of those and by the way those things
actually make you hungry which is not
going to help this plan because you're
going to be starting all the time when
we lower insulin by not eating
carbohydrates we actually live off our
own fat and our hunger goes away now you
also have probably heard of all the fat
burning supplements out there like
Garcinia Cambogia or raspberry ketones
or green tea extract or caffeine or
certain extracts of Chili Peppers all of
these things tend to stimulate your
metabolism but again if you're consuming
things that are increasing your insulin
those are going to be very expensive
urine because they're going to go right
through you they're not going to work so
I wanted to make a big point about that
because you have to understand levels of
importance things that are really really
important and things that are trivial
and things that are dependent on other
things because the last thing I want you
to do is uh you know have this great
diet but you're eating these little
carbs on the side and you kind of
nullify all this good results another
Factor that's very important is the
frequency of eating okay if you're
snacking if you're eating between meals
that can slow things down why because
one of the triggers for insulin the fat
storing hormone is eating in general so
the less you eat the better like two
meals a day or even one meal a day and
one really important point about that
which relates to the next topic which is
bloating is how snacking keeps you
bloated think about what bloating is
bloating involves your digestive system
okay so many people have a big belly
because of bloating they're bloated 24 7
and they think that's fat when in fact
it's sometimes it's not it's just their
digestive system is in a constant state
of working really hard and not digesting
and so so this intermittent fasting is
so important to give your digestive
system a chance to take a break so the
combination of eating too frequent and
overeating will create bloating and I
see it all the time especially when
people after they eat they just like
their stomach is just completely you
know distended if you do infrequent
eating I I promise you you'll do much
much better this happens if you eat and
you get bloated right away it could mean
that you need more acid in your stomach
and I recommend betaine hydrochloride
that's a natural remedy for bloating and
gas things like that and you would
probably want to take quite a few in the
beginning maybe five six or seven small
little tablets right before you eat and
you take that and then you eat and then
you'll find that an extra acid will help
break things down much much better and
in some people they need more bile salts
from their gallbladder so you would take
like a gallbladder formula right after
the meal maybe one or two to help uh
more of that and so the lack of acid and
the lack of bile can create a lot of
digestive bloating things like that and
of course certain things like fruit will
bloat people all day long the sugar in
yogurt can bloat you and of course the
obvious stuff like the beans and the
grains and all that will totally keep
you bloated and even when someone gets
on a ketogenic diet and they have these
little snacks with almond flour and
sugar alcohols like Xylitol erythrotol
oh it's low sugar but they put all these
sugar alcohols that will just bloat the
heck out of you and then also these new
functional fibers like tapioca fiber or
soluble corn fiber boy that will just
bloat you and these so-called clean
healthy plant-based
green shakes or protein shakes you look
at the ingredients there's like millions
of things in there all these fruits all
these different fibers well you drink
that you're just going to be bloated
walk around just feel distended not good
if you're trying to have a flat stomach
and that relates to if you have IBS or
some type of inflammatory condition in
your gut and you're doing salads and
you're doing nuts and things like that
you probably want to go on the carnivore
for a while because if you have bloating
you're not going to be able to digest
these things and all it's going to do
it's going to ferment in the wrong place
it's going to ferment in your small
intestine when it should ferment in the
large intestine and fermentation is
basically where the microbes are eating
up the sugars in it the last thing I'm
going to mention and that is stress
cortisol cortisol is a stress hormone
that will literally not only cause
bloating but also the stress basically
turns things into more sugar and then
that causes more fat so when I mentioned
the insulin being a really key factor in
whether you're going to lose weight or
not cortisol is almost at the same level
if you're going through high stress it's
going to nullify some of the results so
this is why the best thing for stress is
the walking
other types of exercise physical work
and sleeping okay very important to fix
the sleep as well
the other challenge that happens with
women that are postmenopausal is that
their adrenal glands are now having to
back up the ovaries and so we have the
situation where now they get more belly
fat so make note of that and do what you
can if you're going into menopause but I
can't overemphasize the very important
diet that you need to be on and for that
you should watch this video right here